[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais pas sanitaire c'est quelque chose
qui est autoritaire qui met pas mal de
gens se les gens qui sont pas vaccinés
sur pandore en dehors des coups
puisqu'on ne rien faire même pour aller
même pour aller le x 2 billets à biotech
on a demandé le pacha rynair dont on ne
veut pas s'asseoir pour prendre un café
je vais annoncer quelque chose
autoritaire et à la nuit de fascisant
moi d'ailleurs el menzah
[Applaudissements]
le pôle sanitaire ça n'est pas du tout
du tout aux sanitaires c'est un pass
vaccinale et ses politiques c'est un pas
soir c'est à dire un objet de soumission
soit vous vous soumettez à la volonté de
l'état j'avoue n'avait plus aucun droit
on est en voie de devenir comme le parti
communiste chinois c'est à dire vraiment
une dictature
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]